[Music]
and don't discriminate news don'ts
submitted by this isn't jkp da after
receiving his fourth DWI a man argues
that the legal limit discriminates
against alcoholics the dope is argument
I've ever heard of my life or maybe he
identifies as sober try that oh my god
what if we start using the laws of
reversing it that way pretty that's
what's happening right now that sounds
like a good stand a bit but that's some
real-life [ __ ] huh yep so this man from
San Antonio he's arguing that the Texas
legal limit on intoxicated driving
discriminates against alcoholics because
they don't take into consideration how
taller they are tolerances I could take
my drink that's amazing that's just like
saying some states I'd uh legally if you
have a penis you're a guy but you say
you can't you have to take into
consideration that there are you know
identify his men I was driving one time
with a friend of mine I was probably 19
years old I look over and I see my
grandpa's Lincoln Towncar and I look
behind the wheel sure enough it's my
grandfather I was like oh [ __ ] that's my
grandpa so that answers probably [ __ ]
2:00 in the afternoon gotta [ __ ] Crown
Royal in his hand from his lap the cat
had like whisky on the rocks glass
I could see it clear as day and he's
just sort of gingerly like fancy God's a
little thing like you know look at the
light Legion town cards were very smooth
though Oh their tanks that guy wasn't
gonna die everyone else was good I
laughed my [ __ ] ass off I couldn't
believe my grandpa was drinking like
drinking and driving like so casually
some people other tolerance I mean yeah
he never got in trouble the older
generation I feel like they're so
cavalier about they're breaking the law
it just almost seems like it is the law
but every day they don't give a [ __ ]
like they're drinking in a building you
like what's wrong with you that's right
I didn't the way the ice was bossing
around the glass like it's like I could
hear the hiking here
while he's still at our car still
rumbles oh yeah listen to talk radio
just [ __ ] having the day I used to
take ecstasy and drive all the time all
right well I don't identify a sober I
identify as being pretty [ __ ] up so I
don't think I'd be able to drive I
remember I was sitting in the backseat
there was three of us and I was in the
middle so I could see everything that's
going on and all the lights were [ __ ]
with my eyes into a rolling all over the
place like this there's no way I could
it's [ __ ] hard
how did you stay focused tell you
something
the most difficult thing ever no it took
ambition persistence perseverance that
those how old were you like 14 yeah you
have to take a little bit more ecstasy
every time to drive a little bit better
yeah and it's a lot of change okay
that's the new sport I would watch this
stuff I probably drive like 20 miles per
hour
hey I wouldn't be able to stay focused
Indy 500 and you have to take some sort
of substance it's like mushrooms LSD I
think I would like rollerskates more
than that car people like already
go-karts would you go for that they're
coming back I haven't seen that [ __ ] in
and rollerblades rollerblades really I
mean aside from like the beach you know
I mean with you know with the shirtless
guy that Venice Beach always same guy
yeah yes it's the same cat he's doing
like ballet moves yeah there's like two
roller bladers in all of Venice Beach
you guys remember when rollerblades
first came out you know it was like but
people were still rolling skating too it
was that transition right so my mom gave
me like these hand-me-down roller skates
and all of my friends had these fresh
ass blades and I was like the guy in the
back going shh shh shh
following and I'm like please and she's
like you have to learn these first
before I'm gonna get you a solid pair
you know actually
the other way around I learned with
blades and I can never do it with
regular roller skate they're actually
different now they're completely
different roller blades were really fun
but now you just get made fun of when
you wear them especially at this size it
just looks really weird dick oh my god I
need to get you to [ __ ] roller blades
you know like I I know I'm scared of
motorcycles but I'm more scared of the
ridicule of me being on one plus you get
where they help me get where the elbow
pads knee pads shin go [ __ ]
motorcycle or the roller blading for
some reason but on most of you wear
leather helmet it's it's so weird the
like when you're a kid like your sense
of like pain and fear is so much lower
because I remember we said the steep
driveway we would get these long like
[ __ ] planks of wood and we would just
go down it as fast as possible it's
gonna jump that [ __ ] and I would scrape
up my elbows pus is coming out of like
okay I do it again over and over and
over yeah I think when I was a kid I'm
thinking how can I die today without
thinking of death right like what can I
jump this roof without dying today
yeah like dude my niece is no different
like I have a two-year-old niece who
just basically tries to kill herself all
day she walks up to a flashlight she
tries to eat the flashlight don't eat
the flashlight see then she walks over
she tries to break a glass and like
[ __ ] eat it's like no stop what are
you doing but she instantly does
whatever she's doing and like tries to
kill herself with it like it's crazy but
she walks over to the toilet and tries
to [ __ ] drink out of it and falls in
like it's like that's what I mean
everyone's trying to kill themselves I
think until your wheelers all red it
goes into a [ __ ] like meeting dude it's
true but like like when you're but then
you're 2500 us and you're like oh [ __ ] I
could die okay nevermind I'm gonna stop
I'll call be good now I wish I wasn't so
aware of pain mmm yeah because when
you're younger that pain is just like a
natural thing it's like yeah of course
it hurts but I think as you get older is
just like I trying to feel that like I
don't want I don't want to kind of be
comfortable now
yeah about this man trying to argue that
the alcohol limit is discriminating
against alcoholics well he is hilarious
and he needs his own f especial does he
have any sort of case so they like yeah
funny cuz he didn't have
case at all he could not prove that the
law treat alcoholics differently than
other DWI defendant I have a case so
let's say you are over the limit but you
are able to pass all the tests that the
police tell you I touch your nose say
the alphabet backwards do all the N you
bet yeah are you able to pass because
then if you can really show that even
though you're past the alcohol limit but
you can drive better than a regular
sober asian person then is that okay I
agree if you could pass the sobriety
test you're chill yeah that's why I
always would refuse the breathalyzer
thing no chance give me a field sobriety
test but oh yeah you give the option
make me walk on them I think they do I
haven't had it that's like skill-based
cuz I also have somebody who would just
blue like a 0.1 but he's still crashed
into another car in front of him just
because of that small little delay so it
was just that person slammed his brakes
and he just BAM white one is not like
you drink kombucha tea and you're yeah I
didn't really yeah I drank and I started
getting Asian glow my kombucha alcohol
in there really small I'm sensing it I
don't know I mean people when they when
they blow into the alcohol breathalyzer
it really depends on whatever however
your body processes it because for me
like if I have like two beers I won't
blow it yeah I won't you know my point
zero two and I'm [ __ ] yeah dude some
hard liquor best me up because now I
need like six beers to get anywhere so
I'm like there's not worth it like I
will these fool my you're already full
by the time yeah yeah it gave me alcohol
vapor I'm done
really yeah I'm just like man I smell it
just the [ __ ] open up a like that I'm
[ __ ] like is that a product I had a
mess call mule Moscow Mule nobody is a
mess mezcal yeah the smoky yeah actually
what is that good good but hell yeah
love it has like this little smoke taste
- it's [ __ ] touch of smoke I love I
love it
mules are my drink now what's a mule
Musk animals he's pretty good I tried on
the restraint meds
ginger beer vodka and a splash of lemon
is miss caught me with agave - no uh-oh
I don't know good question how this is
really good
man you're making you one right now god
[ __ ] ana 2:00 p.m. you see yeah my man I
did terrible at audition I was like I
can never get past that alcohol flavor
like it makes my nose do this well stop
it makes my nose how's your nose like a
fish kill there like wrinkles I just
dropped my note right nostril
am i doing it no yours is yours it's
also my own affair I don't know well you
should try meh Scarlett's dope I get
jealous because everyone gets to bond
and have fun and get drunk and I just
I'm annoyed because it smells nasty
maybe you just have to do it kind of
like you guys are trying to treat your
allergies where you put yourself like at
the epicenter of the [ __ ] allergy
inducing [ __ ] [ __ ] eight hours
straight you don't know how hard I try
we should be we should make you a
tequila brownie that's a key in the lock
kela Bernie how is that different weird
I said a joke
no no you know you you look it's like
good like a weed burn what about a rum
cake well I think so I've pounded her
mom's room key
that was a very weird sentence tell me
we phrased out of that different way
please your mom's rum cake my mom a
drunk cake that you've tried eat like
half of it and I didn't get all here's
the sexual economy remember last night
when you were away I pounded your mom
how was her mom one cake it was awesome
this delicious did you [ __ ] up [ __ ]
up at all but you can taste your honor
is it tequila like that
I'm just [ __ ] around like baked now
reduces the alcohol content which the
flavor stays there but then the alcohol
content so I want to see if he got
[ __ ] up though cuz if he said yeah
then I know it's like it's like Oh buddy
call it a placebo and I didn't get
[ __ ] up at all but you can taste the
rum you could taste it sauce yeah it's
kind of cool now now that I'm older and
you know like when you're younger
especially when you grow with a bunch of
ghetto people all you're supposed to
drink is like 40s and it's hard liquor
as you know they're you're like [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
there's some great mixtures happy you
know what the [ __ ] am I doing with my
life
[Music]